okay guys okay guys it is your boy Sokka
Baba okay know what that skip was uh and
we're back at it we're back at it [ __ ]
it's been ugh I feel like every [ __ ]
time I play this game I totally forget
the [ __ ] controls it gets a hello sir
you should shut up while I let's take a
look shall we go chat okay oh hello like
yeah repair repair how did this cost I
think yeah hello Beth he's good to see
some new faces yeah you mighty mite is
most of all I was out I doubt it
keller a place man i'll write all the
bridges blowing the bridges was the only
thing to do it was the only white yeah
it kind of gonna keep at my own factions
he'll play is baybay pies that way now
this is the little right so what's the
plan somebody must have a goddamn plane
I have our plan batch I have a plan app
that matter I dope out [ __ ] and quests
okay I guess I'm just doing this go to
the town hall and investigate the
situation wow that's really racist
let me investigate the situation where
zpass
and I don't have one I need you see your
pass yeah I never had one no one leaves
that [ __ ] batch okay well I'm sure man
I was always doing I'm sure there's an
emergency plan in place this is my place
is shaking barricaded the enjoyed
[ __ ] that's getting like crazy faster
than your toilet are one part oh [ __ ]
that really [ __ ] me out long who rule
one is running at the [ __ ] away but what
if I got you cornered
[Music]
I should chop you up a joke maybe I'll
find something useful brother ah bloody
even you need to kill him a little
extreme but okay no number three if you
see someone bitten
I hope that the barricades hold check
must be hundreds of them are here
more
and I'm all talked your side here I use
that to throw out aspect [ __ ] out here
that's our sure
yeah really sucks the way out oh thank
you Michelle thank ya keep them wherever
I can okay i guess i'm just taking
anyone's money that's weird hello right
yeah
I hope that the barricades home so i
guess i'm seeing the man of bridges
hello sir cool get some rest
knowing god's name are you and how the
hell did you get inside here now I
family food and medicine well I'm sorry
but that's impossible our surprisingly
we need everything we had okay batch
that's all I have to say to you for now
people are waiting on me and I had
things to do okay Oh press P to skip
this cutscene oh [ __ ] that's a gang
babby that girl's hot as [ __ ] there's
Tatas so what you said the exact same
thing those [ __ ] the police
station d Sam can either things go to
[ __ ] and it's every [ __ ] wit for himself
blushes [ __ ] in the city it's
just like Norman's they got there who
gives a [ __ ] up to get over and they're
just playing for their own team and I
think it's about time we did to say what
are you saying I'm saying that we have
to find that guy in the radio and the
lifeguard we promise it downtown [ __ ]
a lifeguard man if not for him we would
be stuck here like this make the call
make the car batch
Jen are you there yes I'm here were you
able to get anything we're calling it
off come and get us at the sewer exit
wait wait what are you planning to do
look over to survive we need to get down
out of here no one here is gonna help us
we're supposed to be the ones helping
we're the only ones who can
I can help the others I remember that's
bad nice tatas scene listen the best way
to help everyone is to find that guy
from the radio he's the only one who
understands what's going on we're only
wasting our time here
I will with or without your help we're
staying with the plan I'm taking the
cops if I thought so won't make it
without a star you're not true and if
you leave us here without transportation
we're not going to make it either no
one's going to make it if we don't but
very truly the church the police station
police station Jimmy will supply
everyone but the police station those
[ __ ] can fend for themselves then
we'll find the voice from the rain
agreed i'll be at the store exit over
and out ok
okay thank ya thank ya